human fall flat oh
here we go yeah
we were way near the god damn end of it
if only we'd stuck her through it not uh
quit we could have finished it
hey guys can you come back for me nope
nah do you guys forgive me for doing
this
i'm about to do you do not do it no
hold on let us touch the top one
zero
i already i already want to leave i want
to leave
already guys get the boat with me i'm
i don't want to all right bob you got it
i'm going to be
the ideal perfect teammate all right
okay so
where are we going um uh speedboat that
way
oh sorry is there a shortcut that we
could take through there's a pass
over that way because that's that looks
different from what we've seen before so
i don't know if that's like
newer
all right thanks perfect ideal teammate
anytime
so perfect so ideal thank you tell me
when i'm named in the right direction
and i shall commence
well that's into the speed boat i don't
know unless mark wants you to go the
other way i think we're better to get
the speed boat than
trying to do it with we're gonna get the
speedboat in general so let's just all
right i'm taking this to the speedboat
boys all right
perfect did you make it
oh he made it bob i think we're good
excuse me
all right so we just grab it and yoink
it out and grab it from the bottom and
lift a little bit okay well you know
constructive criticism clearly clearly
some of us have never
joined a speed boat into the air all
right so we've got a perfect ideal
teammate and then uh put your back into
it lads
i can't get a lot heavier all of a
sudden i can no longer lift come on i
gotta
go guys you're back in a strong twisting
motion
all right let's go hey wow look at that
it's actually a miracle all right other
way bob
i think i think that way no all right
i'll swip it swoop it around
i think so there's a little gap and i'm
assuming that it's to an area we haven't
been before which might get us close to
the
end mark you're kind of preventing me
from sorry
sorry perfect ideal teammate sorry
oh my god do we help steer it all
by pulling i think if you stay balanced
i think it's all right oh boy we're
slamming it in there perfect
perfect oh that's the boat that's where
we were
that's where we were over there do we
want to explore that
that's also where we were we passed this
part we need to go
over this hip hip hop so you're saying
we should get out and like carry the
boat i guess
i think yeah you keep you keep
i'm really wrenching my spine boss
this is incredible teamwork we've never
worked this well together
ever ideal teammate ideal teammate
across the board all right yeah
okay there we go
okay all right let's do this damn
we did it we could take this bad boy all
the way to the end
there we go oh i may have slightly hang
on can we
can we slosh the boat around a little
and let me i think i can oh there
perfect perfect perfect perfect
i think i can make it oh god no don't
leave them behind
hey guys hey you get a tan yeah don't
fall off man
straight to hell oh god oh ye gods
oh we can make it all the way hell yeah
dude
okay i'll happy hippie captain overboard
what cap overboard
i'm pumped
oh wait no it does go through uh but no
we won't be able to get under the
overpass
i want to try all right okay come on
come on boys oh hell yeah
oh there we go oh my god
hey all right i probably need to get one
more oh actually yeah that's probably
not quite done huh there we go
[Music]
i think it's helping wait i think this
is gonna oh god captain overboard
all right all right we're fine
wave are you still there okay
totally fine i think ideal teammates
[Music]
my hand is stuck around it okay there we
go there we go
now we're going okay i died that's where
you'll respawn like right here and hop
right back in
right where we just came from are you
all the way back at the beginning
no i'm at the broken ship that we uh
let's
lift it up and over okay let me get
a better grip here
oh god i'm witnessing death
oh god no oh
don't worry i'll totally forgive you
hang on dude that's that's uh that's
rough
wait are you no you alright i feel
horrible
hey look look man look oh yeah there you
go we freed him
i'm dying wait could you help for god's
sakes tell me
help me lift come on lift
this thing's heavy oh i died can you
guys stop dying for
two seconds we're almost through i'm not
sure what we're going to do once we get
this no we're going to get it why are we
pulling the speedboat through at this
point
we're gonna get there i think i need to
help you from your side i think that
well there was there was you you jostled
it
we're free we made it now we gotta lift
it again ah
no no no no no it's fine do you think we
put rocks in the speedboat yeah yeah
it's the same solution all right well
we're kind of
stuck on the thing yeah well we won't be
once we get rocks on put rocks on it so
we're not stuck on the
okay no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no we're gonna go excuse
me yeah there we go all right this is
gonna be tricky
i got rocks i'm sinking i'm drowning the
rocks are drowning me
all right no turns out this was a
mistake
oh i'm exactly what we wanted all right
wait i'm gonna bring it over closer
i literally i got it way closer i can't
give anyone
myself for what just transpired no man i
can't
do it okay okay okay
okay all right rock in i got two rocks
like a man she's not really sinking can
you guys actually just
wedge use the speedboat to wedge this
through i'll lay on here
and just wedge me right under okay we'll
need to back up does this reverse the
boat have a reverse function
uh probably oh no i'm whoa hey
are you sure we should show you yeah no
wedge me get me under here yeah i think
i didn't use my zombie strength
to pull this raft shockingly it's
working
i can't tell what's happening but i'm
grabbing things guys
i solved the problem dude bob whoa
where are you going you you had the
brush i'm working on it i'm working on
it hang on
oh there you are hello hello wait mark
mark hey look we made it that's how
you're supposed to solve it
yeah wait do you have some kind of issue
wade what's the deal i we really can't
stop this right now we're kind of
committed
yeah well this seems way too familiar
i don't know wait don't do anything
drastic
okay bob now that i'm off i think you
can get up there
where behind you oh over here yeah come
here eat
oh my god i have a ninja i can't believe
that happened
maybe if i get enough
oh no wait i'm gonna see if there's
anything i can do to help you
all right well what is your problem wade
how can you not get to the speedboat
from there you like pull the speedboat
back towards yourself and hop on i was
trying to it was not pulling
how did you what no it must be all those
rocks hold on
you're just
am i long enough to help you get up to
where i am i'm probably not
i'll get it oh you're talking to him or
me
yeah do you need a hand mark no no no i
had it and
i i swear come on just not giving me a
hand you need to
no no no no i don't i don't need to
again all right because i got it like
first try
yeah i got i've already been up it's the
thing i'm not very good at this game i
feel like marcus
do you mean me where are you at oh
you're up there i'm up here get it get
your rod up here and i'll help you
oh yeah that's the stuff oh boy let it
settle let it settle
all right i have the tip firmly are you
all
are you a pawn i'm oh god damn it i
did this before all right there you go
there you go oh no oh
come on no all right get it back up here
we need we need mark to assist
i would love to assist where am i
i'm a coming all right mark i believe in
you do you need me to catch you
nope yeah i got it hang on no you're in
the wrong direction buddy
something's happening here
i know how this plays out
i'm gonna go on the gondola i think i
think it's like no
mark you gotta help well i'll just get
it in place i'll get it in place i'll
get
get it ready for us you know maybe i'll
inspect it and make sure everything
looks good
how's it looking how's it looking in
there good looks good you know what
actually i have a thought mark here
something yeah what's up what's up this
little dangly do oh
uh where do you need to go move the
gondola a little bit maybe
all right all right all right guys i
sent me the back
yay okay oh yeah baby all right so let
me see if i can grab the uh
thingo here am i the thingo nah
i'm back here though bob mark i'm here
should we go get him
i guess all right okay you got a firm
grasp on it
firm grass get on there wade okay here
we go
whoa whoa oh my god okay physics is a
little funny don't
knock me off oh you guys are doing it if
you could
jump wade if you could jump out oh no
jeez oh geez oh geez
oh geez i shouldn't help at all can you
come closer to the edge maybe and
change the leverage that we have here
i'll let you guys pull it i'm not
holding it
there he
to save me all right hang on what if
what if i what if we just prop it up
against the wall
you know what i mean like probably grab
i'll solve my own problems i'm gonna
hold it against the wall
oh careful oh god it was jiggly it's
probably my fault
here let me let me well i'm just going
to body block it i'm just going to wait
can you
drive the boat possibly and get it any
closer to me can you like turn it
let's switch the sun let me just go to
the side you know what mark
this is not helpful it's not productive
yeah baby yeah baby
back swinging back okay so what i'm
trying to do is if i'm here then
hopefully i'm like an
anchor and it won't move yeah it's on my
head
[Laughter]
i'm dead i'm not getting back up guys
hit a button or something dude i was
trying okay there we go i'm up i'm up
i'm up okay okay okay
dude i was hitting buttons i was not
getting up all right
okay i've got the wall and i've got this
all right i'm in a position
oh it twists yeah that's a little too
close to the wall it's gonna have to be
more
space than that okay okay okay okay all
right try that try that try that
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
calm down there yes all right
who wants to be the danger man who does
the switch i did it before i think i
could do it again
let's do this clunk and
jump
i'm clipped through i am clipping
through
i've clipped i wait uh i've
clipped through i don't think i actually
have mark oh i have my face okay
okay oh my god it's a miracle i'm just
gonna oh
yeah that's good reset right now wade
our friendship would not survive ideal
teammate don't worry buddy ideal
teammate
i'm just gonna shake my head vigorously
for some reason how do you do the head
shaking i don't understand i don't i'm
just holding
x i don't i'm not even holding it i
don't know i don't
understand yeah it just if you fall
backwards with it you just
yeah just kind of do this well i feel so
left out right now i'm not doing that
dude
could be the pole yeah it's the ball
no i just lay down that's not it at all
i'm sinking i'm sinking there i go hey
we made it oh there it goes
hey oh now that we're all taking naps
and stuff i can't get up
getting up getting up getting up there
grab this lever real
quick no no you do not
all right uh we have a chain thingy is
this like a dam that we need to release
it looks like we maybe need to take that
loop around to the other side for some
reason
can we pick this log up oh my god oh my
god a tightrope
no we got a checkpoint here hellfire i
hope so
all right boys let's do this okay
[Laughter]
oh god i couldn't even hit it yeah
didn't make it didn't make it either
the stairs are blocked by this stupid
thing
oh for god's sakes don't don't
i was not doing anything don't do it
brave moves there wade
this is what i was made for this is what
i was made for
i was born for this why aren't you
grabbing the thing
you specifically not grabbing the thing
oh i'm no longer grabbing there we go
yeah one miss grab and it's it's a real
quick down
i feel like mark's better at this than
we are no yeah i was catching up for a
minute and then all of a sudden i
started
sucking lots of dick well that's that's
your problem
yeah it was a very delicious dick no
it's no time for dick sucking
is there such a thing as delicious dick
oh god oh wow whoa
yeah probably i mean if you like the
pineapple
juice the theory oh no that doesn't
affect the taste of the dick itself i
would think
that's what you get for talking about
gross stuff when growth
no delicious no delicious
yeah if my arm could stop reaching
behind my back that'd be i know
great okay i really found my rhythm and
i'm
here nailed it so
what does this switch do let's wait to
find that oh
dude it's the exit guys
wait where'd you go oh i'm back up top
bob you can do it i'm coming man i feel
like there was something to do with that
dam and a raft like because there was a
raft over there i bet you could have
like
i'm trying to figure that out yeah do
you do that if i see the water gush down
and you in a raft i'm gonna be very
impressed
i'm doing it the markiplier way oh i
have an
idea oh i know what your idea is yeah
definitely hook it to the gondola send
the goblin yeah yeah
yeah yeah you you're right you're right
you're right you're right do that
if wade finishes before i do i'm gonna
be very upset with myself
you guys ready for this [ __ ] ready all
right gotta time this perfectly
oh there she goes oh there she goes oh
there she goes
oh there she goes oh there she goes and
the wheels turning too i don't know what
the wheel does
hi bob are you proud of me i'm very
proud of you
are you proud of me dad yeah do you want
to go back up and ride the rafting
no see the thing is i think one of us
had to go here anyway to get in
because otherwise it wouldn't have
opened i think we're slowly going
oh wait wait actually maybe it's a good
idea that i didn't go back wade uh
you getting the raft oh yeah all right
cool have fun
we'll do it die does it not go to the
exit it doesn't seem to
wait what guys are you going gosh
oh my god
guys are you under it right now i'm
under the raft
dude those rapids are what you want oh
no
that's trap it's really good wait did
you let go of the raft
guys so let go of the rest why'd you let
go of the raft
by way
[Laughter]
all right all right shall we bob yeah do
you wanna do it
yeah let's go for it i'm right behind
you did we just jump off
just jump jump oh springboard
oh god oh oh
guys i think i don't think the raft went
the right place
oh no oh
hey what's up guys what's up friends is
this just the next level
yeah we made it
oh i turned it off no i
i stopped it oh you unplugged it all
right we need those cables over here
i don't think they're going to reach no
you can unplug them
oh you're right
oh i could have ridden the wheel up
oh we were supposed to ride the raft and
take the wheel off
oh or do it our way
and i didn't know it was pretty cool i
missed i got
there you got there buddy yeah you know
uh
[Music]
all right
she's a wild one there we go
i'm using weight like a puppet ah how's
it going wade i'm good
is it wade grabass hour i didn't know uh
oh i see i see i see i see i see it's
teaching us
so many things since my sir yeah come on
come on
come on there
there we are there we are oh interesting
interesting
interesting interesting interesting
interesting wait
we're kind of like little electricians
is this like what our job was supposed
to be and we only just now got to the
work site
yes god i hope so interesting
interesting interesting interesting
i shall stand here there's one of your
little fancy go-arounds right here
fancy go-arounds oh my goodness you're
right
can i come back no my plug
my club here mark i'll help you no
don't worry just stay there i'll help
you no no no is this helpful no no
no no no no no
look i'll now all swing around now you
let go and i'll swing you by the gooch
over to the other thing no
no no no no weighing me down very
heavily
come on friend pipe club
my club i'm grabbing something ooch and
i've got the bottom of this
it falls out seeing good thing i was
here oh my god oh my god
oh my god how are you doing is this
working
i'm gonna carry you over to the edge and
you're gonna make it apparently five
club
pipe club no too low
it's almost like something's weighing me
down high club
pipe i'm doing it okay i'm so
almost there i can't pull us
both cannot pull back here
i'll get my other hand on you and there
we go that's perfect
perfect it's perfect do it come on oh my
god it's perfect
it's so perfect climb climb
here reach an arm up over and grab the
ledge
guys i solved the next two areas okay my
goose my god here i'll
i'll take some of the load off here
there you go can you get all right i
shall get it
oh my god bob i hate you so much
ah dang it i can't believe we didn't
make it i hate you
ah well i'm gonna try this again i think
mark messed us up
i hate you hi bob i see you bob
hey where are you at uh behind you busy
doing pipe club stuff
i see i see i see i see
oh interesting interesting interesting
interesting hold mark go
interesting interesting interesting mark
look this is how it's done mark
interesting interesting interesting
interesting very very interesting do you
see this mark
you see how it's done mark i do not see
i do not see
mark you're in the next area i see
interesting interesting interesting
interesting interesting
interesting interesting i feel like
there's something where this battery
doesn't have any charge in it what
i think your battery might be dead
you alright bouncy oh yeah baby pipe
club
yeah hi club pipe club yeah pipe club
yeah whatever i think this battery needs
some charge
it needs some juice hmm come on help me
get it over to the charger
almost looks like there's a charger come
on get it over to the charger
yeah yeah yep oh god oh god you're gonna
hold them both
charger charger here you got it wade you
got it
charlie guys i made a bridge charger
anyone trying to come over here no where
where are you
all right in the room with the treadmill
hey guys come come to the treadmill
guys come see what i found no don't
trust him
he's not a true member of pipe club no
it's a thing for you wade no no no no no
no wait don't do it no no no wait wait
wait don't no
he'll betray you wait remember what he
did last time we played remember i
re he reset the level remember oh you're
right
what a jerk wad right right wade don't
trust him i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
betray you i'm i'm just being
you all right right now he will call
friends
he'll call frames the second the second
you try to love
look how hard i'm holding on to this
lever
oops that was an accident that was an
accident he's betraying you
nah nah mark's betraying you it's mark
no no no no no i would never
oh you just locked mark in his room by
himself savage
in my room by myself you mean in the
next room where the puzzles are being
solved i'm pretty sure we're further
than you now
oh that's pretty sure you are very
stupid
that is stupider than me i think you're
as stupid as you are
ugly and you're as ugly as you
are ugly oh my goodness
mark where are you i'm looking for you
i'm solving things here wait if you want
to go under there just flop down and
i'll totally hump you through
okay don't trust him there we go this
this'll work the hump never works
yeah hang on that'll work you got to get
flatter weight
why are you why are you doing that no no
no no no do not let him shaking your
head you got to flop down
i'm trying wait you're doing it wrong
you're holding you're
really holding up the process wait
you gotta really flop i'm trying there
we go i got it i got it i got it i'm a
genius
i'm the best why do you flop i couldn't
flop forward like i could before
all right all right let's just leave
mark's annoying oh
baby guys uh i feel like this forklift
might need two people
oh are you uh in some sort of trouble no
no i got it
i keep waking up you can hold it dude
you don't wake up if you hold it do you
i thought i was holding it you thought
you were holding it hot wade see how
you're suffering because you chose the
wrong person
i mean we're only going backwards i'm
driving a forklift
stay down there for a minute hang on
yeah there you go how do you like that
there you go i'm having so much fun
forklift over here no no no i'm having
the time of
my existence i don't think i can get
back up at this point
no you're fine you're fine see he
betrayed you
i would never do that oh no
did you just take this box back over
there to mark i don't need a box
i've got a forklift
oh you want to use it i am using it good
you use it more effectively to do what
forklift
things yeah i will i am and i have been
not that you would know anything about
that traitor that um
that metal thing there looks like a
problem well what happens when you pull
that lever
i'm having the time of
my life mystery
forklift mark almost done almost done
baby almost done
i think wade and i are pretty much
becoming the best at this game
well it's impossible because i'm already
here uh we're already
here so yeah uh-huh yeah
what do you have to say about that the
us that is we
is was here already
[Applause]
oh i see i see yeah
yeah yeah yeah for like a second
and then stop it oh wait a minute
what the hell wait what
you're safe what
how's it going mark with your stupid
forklift you a-hole
all right uh bob we're doing the same
thing to get these wires i think
we could take care of these wires in the
last room we might need them at some
point though
okay i'm okay okay hey
oh hey mark look we've been here this
whole time
oh it's my time to shine
i've done it i'm the greatest there ever
wasn't it
it's way easier than that well we need
to grab those wires
my hand's caught my hand is literally
caught my hand's got there we go
grab the wires oh yeah
no leave it on we could just keep trying
all right
hey i got one i've got one i'm glad
someone's useful i got one
i got it hey i got it
the red right mark which color which
color are we trying to plug it in
i did it i did i did that one i didn't
think wade
hey
like the forklift i'm the master of this
there we go in there
yeah don't worry get out of the way okay
watch this
oh restart my computer you say
even my computer's done with my [ __ ]
there we go watch okay there you go guys
thank you there you go guys
you're welcome guys okay so now we need
that battery back i think the whole
load oh yeah yeah
oh guys there's a problem with your
logic
i think we might need to leave the
battery plugged in and then move the
battery so it like props
yeah that's what i do out
you're dragging four balls i just see i
see
oh there we go there's well there's some
stuff in there don't worry about it
they're just balls for me too all right
now hold that there and i'm gonna
have to have it under the door no we can
close this door now we just take the
wires out we don't need that door open
oh okay so i should be over here
i see bold strategy in the hole in
[Music]
[Music]
and i don't know if batteries on the
wires are gonna work like that well i
was trying to flip it over it just
happened to flip it in the hole
in the hole in the hole in the hole
in the hole in the hole
and the steam roll me someone please
steamroll me
hey look guys i got the cord from out
from under the other door oh no the ball
is stuck
oh we got it we got another record we
got a board we got to get coal in the
burners i think
interesting well that one's already
going
cold and the coal in the hole
oh um who wants to drive
we gotta go up to the coal mountain up
top the hill oh hell yeah
okay this one i don't know all right
guys i guess i'll uh
i said hell yeah give me a [ __ ]
oh no wait guys i'm inside the i'm
inside the thing hang on
okay there we go all right how do i
drive is it in the back there
there's a wheel up here oh hell yeah
it's like the forklift i was driving
earlier
i drove a forklift i wanted you all to
know that i
expertly navigated the forklift
and blah blah blah blah blah blah
is that really full speed ahead oh yeah
there we go
oh it's out of control oh god be careful
oh my god oh no we're out you're on full
speed so full speed i'm going back here
to the market
we're not even gonna stop when we get to
the coal you guys better just chuck it
in here fast
all right sounds good boss oh man that's
hard to turn that much
oh boy oh boy yep boom here we go
wait a minute no hang on back her up a
little bit
back her up oh i fell off the side all
right sure
good good moves there buddy
there we go let's do this
hey we got an achievement festival head
come on wade jam it in there all this
stuff that's another truck don't worry
all right you ever you know when we're
stopping yeah not yet
oh no we don't fit no we fit we'll fit
slowly yeah now we're now we're slow
enough do it do it do it do it
there you go there you go back up back
up
back up back up back up back up back up
back up back up
oh no wait dude if you fall off it's not
death wade you're not on the edge of his
mouth run over
well that's your problem close enough
that's close enough all right
okay there we go how do we fill it up
now we go into the coal mine and do some
stuff or
uh yeah we erase these two dump trucks
that we have
or i don't know the coal mine should not
be on fire
yeah that's that's a bad thing no i'm
gonna put this in the coal truck we
probably need this to start the burner
you're right you're right you're right
when you're right you're right guys look
i have the torch
light them up
that doesn't seem safe
i don't know if osha would approve of
this they should just put the flaming
torch
it's fine it's like american express or
whatever it's everywhere it wants to be
uh yeah yeah that's their slogan
american express we're on fire
[ __ ] yep oh i just dunked myself in
the truck a little bit oh no i'm coming
back don't worry guys oh
oh oh yeah dodges john's is the rock
dodge is the rock
you guys see that [ __ ] yeah how about
you load some coal
listen we all agreed that the fire was
important too i was just making sure we
got everything we needed
good point that's fair like the dramatic
music are we all about to get black lung
or something
me the black loner blasted into
yesteryear a drama
about a cold town and our dad worked the
whole mines and now we're
we don't want to be him but we're doing
his job yeah and then renewable energies
are coming in those evil
evil solo panels companies that just
want to ruin the earth with their
stupid silicone renewable energy sources
i don't think we need every last hunk
listen we're environmentally
you underestimate our miners
and we're going to be rich and that's i
saved these skull
these coal scraps i sacrificed my body
but now the coal will not go to waste
that's good as it should be that's all
the company asks of us
excuse me i'm playing hopscotch oh i ask
of
you isn't that like a disney song or a
sure oh yeah
let it cool let it coal you okay there
mark
yeah i got there we go we're good and
now we ride it back
up i think some of this coal might be
slightly magnetized and or magic there's
one down here that's just sticking to
the side of the conveyor belt
not going anywhere but not touching
anything
all right is this actually going into
the oh no guys
guys guys guys
guys don't worry mark i'm coming oh
something bad is that oh no
yeah i think it was the stick
oh no guys oh
no all right mark don't worry don't
worry we're all gonna come help
any second now dude i can't even get out
now this is fine you just gotta you just
gotta lift dig and lift
dig and lift dig and lift
i thought you made sure that the stick
got in there wasn't that like your thing
i made sure it was on the conveyor belt
and it got in there
uh-huh it's totally fine don't worry dig
and lift
dig and lift dig and lift hey mark i'm
inside now and i can no longer move but
i see it i see you
yeah the problem is the stick hey i got
through the problem is 100
the stick you guys are right that was a
bad idea
all right i guess i'll go back around
and try and come help i don't know
oh god we might need a frames we
might need a friend no we're so fine
i'm falling
well i'm stuck in a different place is
that better or worse
okay there you know i got out i got out
i got out i got out i'm coming back i'm
coming back this is fine
wait your laughter is not moving coal
very much
i just want you to know that it's just
wait listen the futility of this
exercise may be hilarious i recognize
that but
but but but you're not working all right
i think i've got a hand on the stick
i'm not 100 sure i think i do
all right i need to pull you out pull my
head yeah pull me
see what you can do or get out of the
way i was trying to hold that bit of
okay
oh damn it i didn't have it damn it it's
okay we have we have like an access hole
here we're close yeah let me
let me try to i can't see anything
i think this is this is like allegory
for our our
greed to get all the coal so we're being
buried in it
just keep digging just keep digging a
hole eventually it has to work right
eventually i'm falling
[Applause]
hey oh it did it's still stuck wait the
coal's still stuck but we got the match
up
no no it's fine we got enough it's cool
i'm going back
up okay i'm proud of us i'm proud of us
thanks
i'm proud of us hello hey wait you got
it
good job there's still more no
give me some juice all right not too
much
not too much a little juice is that
enough juice
yeah just keep it here for a minute keep
it here mike you've been here for a
minute
all right we're gonna we're gonna pull
around this way and then
around this way a little bit and then
hit me with some backup juice
backing up backing
all right four juice okay
forward juice wait are you having some
kind of trouble
i'm trying to put this last piece of
coal in the pot it's definitely worth it
backing up we'll get there we'll get
there we'll get there no back up back up
back up back up
no there's a if we go straight ahead
isn't this the road
just no we won't bat we want to go back
to whence we came don't we no there's
another one
there's another room oh yeah okay let's
do it
full speed ahead oh really slam on it
there's another gear you gotta just
all right full speed really yoink it i'm
joining
wait how'd you make it go faster push it
forward harder
we got a heavy load boss
it's not that heavy you really get both
hands on it okay okay let me i'm trying
it again
oh there we go you were right boss
you're right you're right i was wrong
oh that's the edge oh mama i will not
let go of this
time for some downhills baby
no we're fine so fine i'm an excellent
driver
i know this i know this about you i'm an
excellent captain i'm an excellent
leader
[Music]
hey the exit is right there guys the
eggs is right there
that's close to the edge close to the
end that's wow
i'm living on the edge baby yeah you are
yeah we're dying on the edge too
that's possibility uh we ain't die we
fine
all right all right little bits at a
time that's all we need little bits
very proud of us i'm proud of us
delivery balls slippery boy
wow all right park this monster let's do
this all right and three two
one pulling oh yeah
hit the dump right behind you guys oh
can we can we lift it up and dump it
yeah yeah i got it
right here oh there's a
i see i was gonna try and dump it with
my arms that would be weird
are we dumped uh i hope so
oh yeah all right wait where where what
wait
i got the other truck don't worry wait
wait what why
wha what don't worry mark what why
greed all right i call it idiocy
he calls it greed ah the same thing
right okay i solo move this truck into
position and i'm gonna solo drive it
down just you wait hey as the man who
soloed that forklift
i get it i get it you know there's not
even video evidence that you did
anything with it
full of [ __ ] there's plenty of video
evidence
um i mastered it do not
dude do not we will destroy you
don't but i said frames
death will befall you you will
suffer uh eternal pain oh hey cool
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no
how are you stronger than me i'm fine
fine let go of me let's hold me fine
fine fine fine so you get for throwing
coal at me
i didn't throw coal honestly guys
there's only like a couple little ones
not even worried about it on the way
back
good are you sure it's all good you sure
you want to make that judgment call
wait yep all right bob did you know we
were playing with a quitter
i thought he was a champion yeah
apparently not apparently champs on the
way back
oh who who's that who could that be
buckle up
no need to worry wait a little bit need
to worry a little bit need to worry that
doesn't sound good
are you about to knock all of our coal
that we have off the mountain stuff
pretty good right there
pretty good right there good work wade
yeah okay how do we know if we've got
enough
i don't know good question hey you got
more coal man you have to light it do we
just need to light on fire i'll try with
what i got let me see if it actually
does anything
okay fire going in all right
fire going in fire oh
okay that one could use a little more
coal in that one so that one needs a few
more sticks
i mean rocks sorry i know the difference
more sticks
okay what does that do is it like a jump
pad it's like a turbine
oh i'm either going to get chopped to be
ah
i'm not good or bad it's good it feels
real good
uh this is not gonna oh there you are
what kind of [ __ ] you get up there
not gonna work oh it works shockingly oh
i see bob into the nuclear
power plant yipes
oh i don't think this is gonna work
that's what i said but then it worked
my body my body what happened to my body
okay pulling up would be great there we
go oh hey
how'd you make that jump um good
question
let's wait for bob bobby you're here no
i goofed
bob don't goof i goofed bob don't
i did it already it's too late bob don't
it's too late
bob stop bob do you no
hi bob hi friends yeah you jumping
around you just have to make it to the
ledge and then
slide down are these glowing from
radiation or something or
no you made it okay all right uh
i'll i'll try not to jump oh god
okay here we are hold on to my hand bob
no i'm good we'll go together three
two one
oh okay oh okay ah
did i go first yeah
oh god oh hey look there's these matches
holding this big rock here
um boeing wow
well wait no no that's supposed to do i
don't think yeah that that didn't feel
right
excuse me squish me reset it i want to
be squooshed
oh chris you guys ready yeah crush me
who are you
i'm i live mark mark seems fine
surprisingly
i live is that what we're supposed to do
uh no i think it's just to teach you
that you can and we're supposed to do it
to that one over there
get this other stick off of my stick
don't worry i lift stick with
with two hands four hands four hands
yours doesn't go under ours goes under
lift i did it it was all me
what the a-hole don't worry
i i bring there's only a hole big enough
seemingly for a stick here
good thing i brought a stick yeah i
brought a stick
not like that dumbass oh it's big
don't worry i helped you oh thank you
guide the shaft in here all right push
push wait uh push i'm not even touching
the stick
push pushing all right yoink
yoinking yoinking which way are we
yoinking here
i'm yanking toward you yeah i'm yonking
this way as well
oh it's moving there we go there we go
oh
[ __ ] all right that should be good right
well it doesn't really help us get
through when you
do it like that wait don't leave it
there how
was it you blocked it up perfectly thank
you
mark just wanders in yeah
later put it on the ground and slice
lava has no bottom
you're saying the lava has no bottles
lava has no bomb
has no bottom lap i wonder if you can
jump over on this side over here
the answer is yes you can um what the
[ __ ]
what's up well i found what we need to
do with the uh i'm too
i uh i weigh pounds huh i have
weight what's your point my weight is
keeping me from getting boxed
okay can you can you just give me a hand
here
oh i am moving it is this good
bad where you trying to go bob i'm just
trying to get it up top i guess this is
futile did i help you guys or did i hurt
you guys
you made it harder for us to get into
the thing that's good that's good that's
good that's where i need it
but aren't you just gonna counterbalance
mark for a moment but there's a box here
i can get
perfect perfect perfect what was the
point of that
to get this oh to do what now we gotta
lower them
whichever side needs weight we put this
on and it holds the weight
ah yes yes uh interesting interesting
right we don't need to say it so
condescendingly i didn't it was
interesting you don't need to say it so
russianly
i don't know i think over there but we
need like something to stand under
counter balancing
is that wait wait do that actually is
the box in here it's totally in here
come here see your box yeah bring the
box
we can't go any further down well stay
where you are then
i will bring the box to you okay
then i think we might need two one
person to get off on the side
and that you're on and then two of us to
go counterweight the other side to
raise the box up never mind you got it
just silly man
i think we need to go
good thing we got this box over here all
right let's throw that off the edge i
didn't throw it
i just set it aside to take a pixie it
has no use
box
a box but better oh i shouldn't talk
[ __ ]
yeah oh i didn't make it
hey i'm glad we're all equally [ __ ]
whoa hey can someone counter balance me
so i can get back up and try and get the
box
or how about you just knock the box off
with the stick but i like
my oh
why don't you just stand on the other
end you know you guys got it you guys
got it you guys got it you guys got it
meanwhile i
just shove it under there bob working on
it oh god my
spine mark grab it on it grab what
bob's dick stick what i what
whoa
what are you trying to do get this
wedged under it needs to go across to
the other side
or you could knock the box out with a
stick you know what
i'm trying to help wade see his vision
okay
that looks wedged that looks wedged hang
on hang on that's
that's pretty wedged of you mark god i'm
lifting off the ground
okay i made it i'm up good job
yeah good job wade do it to me take it
off
take it all right i caught it with one
hand
so strong where's this gotta go um
counterbalance
you mean over here so now we need the
stick out right
yeah yeah here let me put a bunch of
weight on that so it's really hard to do
hang on is
[Applause]
let me get up here let me get up here
totally fine
all right going how the hell i don't
think this is the second one
yeah wait yeah got it here mark
yeah what's up you want me to help okay
i got a guy yeah hey
maybe someone who's not an idiot should
do the counterbalance
that goes quick yeah see i'm not an
idiot you're an idiot
so what are we just doing a leap of
faith i think so yeah good work gus
hey yeah oh my god oh my god
all right mark just you now i'm coming
we all made it friend
[Laughter]
well
[Laughter]
the box went way way higher than you
did it was so sad mom can you grab
it no you got it come on man
that was pretty coming man mark here
funny guy you know what
totally intentional the only thing
funnier if i had plummeted to my death
yeah you know
just like that
there we go where am i going where am i
going where am i going
oh where am i going okay those don't
feel right
bob what do i do i'm not sure what do i
do
stay right there i got you i got you i
got you hang on stay right there
and then and then i'm going to just
slide slide this
off
okay oh no that was according to plan
[Applause]
should i die
i can flip
[Laughter]
[Music]
mark i'm really sorry about that that's
my that's my bad man
there he goes wait i don't know what you
thought was going to happen but
oh my god
no all right
oh that was way short that was pathetic
oh come on
he couldn't make it not everything's
hilarious wait come on
everything's fine you like wind up take
one baby
okay yeah can you just jump from the
stage to where i'm at right here
oh you're right oh you're you're well
there we go
you are correct you're right you're
right okay
oh don't hold don't hold hands that's
not what i'm doing
oop hello hey what's up
what what what's funny now what what
could possibly be hilarious to you
this didn't help us wait no we needed to
get the block on the thing
i thought bob pulled the block off the
thing now i'm both how did that help
us okay wade i've got it
i've got it do you you wade you
can make it on uh are you trying to do
what i was trying to do
yeah yeah yeah oh that's a really hard
job apparently hang on hang on
yeah i can't do all the jumps guys you
have to make one of them
this is going to make it made it
all right okay now if you get on there
wait
wait wait wait not yet you said get on
there
no i said if he said i said i said
okay okay okay actually i think that's
working right mark that's what we want
yeah yeah this is what we want
maybe oh i got off can i why'd you get
off why didn't you go up on the ledge
over there
i came from right here oh never mind
then this is cool guys the whole new
area
you could have gone there and it yeah
oh hey mark wait did you just die
and go to where he is yep yeah i got
checkpoint
i guess i'll die well all right then
that was fun it was a fun little puzzle
i liked that one it was fun yeah fun
fun puzzle
[Music]
you